lief pokémon um 14 uhr direkt nach der
schule pokemon geschaut dann kam mal
zwei folge meine eltern man halt weg und
ich dann so wie bed boy ist es 15 uhr
ich guck mal weiter dann kann man dieses
intro von jogi und ich dachte das ist
meine serien hallo ich meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren folge minecraft wald
leben zusammen mit beckers sohn und herr
bergmann hallo hallo hallo überhaupt das
erstmal die frage ziel sind ja das ist
jetzt das erste mal dass wir diesen
kompletten kreislauf durchgemacht haben
mit diesen drei mal hochladen und bei
mir kamen zumindest heute schon
kommentare höhe kommt heute noch wald
leben also leute an alle die dies noch
nicht verstanden die können mal in die
beschreibung gucken und zwar hab ich da
einfach alle tage hin geschrieben das
heißt ihr seht da beispielsweise
bergmann dienstag donnerstag kinos
mittwoch freitag und samstag mit woods
am samstag egal da stehen auf jeden fall
die die tage und ich würde sagen wir
haben in dieser folge ein thema oder
möchte noch jemand von euch irgend etwas
organisatorisches bringen ich möchte
einspruch erheben
wofür ich hole ok boss lieber konkret
mit einem thema los wir müssen erst mal
kurz einen kleinen plan aufstellen soll
machen weil wir dies dorf einfach mal
ein bisschen reparieren was wir wollen
das feld genau wo konkret also genau da
wo konkret in die richtung genau mit
meiner rechten den besten weg eine
vision weg wie ich bin schon war's
einfach jetzt
du bist du entweder direkt aber wer hat
mich dann abgeschossen ich dachte du
hättest mich abgeschossen das ist
relativ ausgelassen skelett wir sollten
uns auch darum kümmern also ich hab
jetzt hier so ein paar karotten und so
ich werde einfach mal die felder dass
man vielleicht stehen und dann kann ich
die immer weiter mit mit mit kram voll
packen und dann sollte sich jetzt
vielleicht jeder mal nebenbei anfang
irgend so eine kleine bude zu bauen ich
habe die kirche schon in beschlag
inklusive priester der gehört zum
inventar
das heißt bauen uns jetzt einfach zu
diesem dorf dazu ja da bauen jetzt
einfach unsere hütten rein würde ich
würde ich mal vorschlagen wenn ich und
wie ganz ganz erster nächsten hinten
rein und dann mit fortdauer des
projektes dann irgendwie ziehen unsere
eigenen hütten weil ich bin echt gern
was auf dem wasser bauen mit bambus
ja ich brauche ich baue gerade meine
eigene hütte baue ich schon um gute
priester gehört mir bitte dass meine ja
das ist in ordnung
microsoft wird mein seelenheil wenn ich
noch verantworte ich habe jetzt andere
shader geholt da ist wenn man auch die
steine mit leiterin aber das wasser als
ein bisschen cooler das ist schwimmt
jetzt so richtig cool und läuft besser
und bei nacht ist das ganze auch cool
aber ich hab einen drauf aber nichts
verändert
außerdem steht ein guter soll einfach
mit dem ersten thema anfangen gehört
irgendjemanden das alles ist ein haus
gekracht
ja da wohl nicht zur zeit und während
ich mir da so ein neues kauft du hast da
schon die hälfte und abgeholzt oder hast
du das ja das war ich vermutlich sieht
schön aus nicht los
ja genau und zwar haben wir in der
letzten folge schon gesagt das erste
wort ist welche ich glaub ich hab mal
die kommentare geguckt ich glaube keiner
hat so wirklich erkannt war auch echt
schwer weil welche kann man damit kann
man so gut wie jede frage einleiten
die frage kommt von batu ja wie immer
mit dem hashtag waldleben bei twitter
geschrieben
batu ja bzw bad place sagt serien früher
und jetzt also welche serien haben wir
früher geguckt und welche für serien
haben wir
schauen wir zurzeit uns war es alles
halt so ein bisschen unsere meinung was
das ganze angepasst und gute serien gut
und schlecht gibt es eigentlich gar
nicht also welchen geschmack haben jeder
was er ihn an geht er so das
actionreiche sogar eher was die pils
oder ja was witziges oder eher was kurz
ist und das wollte erhält von uns wissen
wenig anfangen
ich habe jetzt mal schon angefangen
kinos verein glaubt reinhauen also es
ist tatsächlich so dass ich serienmäßig
was so kindheitserinnerungen habe habe
ich irgendwie wenig ja ich weiß dass ich
immer dragon ball z durfte war dass alle
in der grundschule damals vielleicht
sogar schon geguckt haben aber das kam
spät abends um sieben ja- und so
fürsorglich wie meine eltern war ich
natürlich sehr dankbar bin
durfte ich das lange lange lange zeit
die schauen weil da geht es ja auch um
gewalt und höchste wesen und um kameras
und blut und schläge und also was und
damit ich dann nicht zu so einem kleinen
miniatur superstar john key hat das
lange gedauert bis ich das gucken durfte
als ich dann gesehen habe war es
natürlich eine eine wunderschöne zeit
damit
und auch ansonsten so ein bisschen so
dass rtl2 mittagsprogramm die animes
durchgecheckt und hin und wieder auch
mal bestimmt auf tiger heidi und nils
holgersson in ganz frühen kindertagen
und heutzutage trifft man mich
eigentlich in allen möglichen serien an
meine meine lieben mit kommentatoren
hier und zwar abbrechen bett gelegt die
schau liebend gerne game of thrones
american horror story habe ich ganz
lange jetzt angefangen und feiert das
auch recht gut ja ehrlich du kannst
kannst du dir das kannst du dir das das
ist doch wirklich innovative ist halt
nur muss man ganz groß ein haken game of
thrones haake eine sache die wirklich
von allen so gehypt wird wenn ihr das
nicht kennt ich schreibe euch das mal
vielleicht france hat sich auch mal
komisch an so wird das geschrieben könnt
ihr einfach mal googeln ist glaube ich
mittlerweile schon die beliebteste
fischer heißt die epische serie wir aber
schon deutlich als dieses repositories
oder ich weiß es nicht genau das jetzt
bezeichnen würde aber viele preise
bekommen hat mir davon ein paar wochen
angucken das einzige was gesehen hat war
nackte frauen nackte männer yards und
gewalt ja das ist halt nicht so meine
serie was ich wirklich geliebt hat war
damals die tournee folgen mit charlie
sheen das fand ich echt das war
unglaublich witzig weil es einfach
wichtig sein abbild von charlie sheens
wirklichen leben war und das war echt
echt schön was ich sonst noch richtig
toll auch geschaut was er gesagt hat es
breaking bad wirklich breaking bad ist
für mich immer noch die beste serie
produziert wurde
finde ich echt habe ich jede folge von
geguckt teilweise mehrmals noch mal auf
englisch um das ganze in den emotionen
und in den gefühlen besser rüber zu
bekommen bekommen zu tun haben seien und
was ich auch noch sagen kann ist dass
ich bei breaking bad wirklich die
einzige serie war wo ich geweint habe
zwischendrin und wo ich so richtige
schockmoment aber sonst habe ich so eine
serie kalt gelassen
aber genau das macht für mich hat jetzt
eine gute serie aus und ich kann auch
schon sagen was ich in zukunft schauen
werde und zwar das house of cards ich
weiß nich kennt ihr das
ich könnte mir da etwas also nicht
sportlich gesehen ist auch sowas auf
meiner liste steht weil sie aber ohne
nicht ob das so könnt ihr mir irgendwie
verfehlen
ich habe nur die ersten beiden folgen
gesehen die fand ich ganz gut also ich
mag kevin spacey sehr gerne ich mag den
auf wundervoll häufig machen ich mache
den 100 wunderschöner man einfach
wunderschön eigentlich sehr sehr geil
ich finde eine schauspielerische
leistung müsste mit lorbeeren beworfen
werden also ich weiß wurde sie völlig zu
recht oscar american beauty ehrlich für
die serie
nein für den film ready to marry you die
nicht ich kann ihn für mich
ja natürlich immer dämlich brennt alter
das ist ja unglaublich
es geht ja gar um serien satellite birgt
manche manche das wahrscheinlich ist
dass ein klassiker oder ja also jetzt
hier bevor es jetzt losgeht und sagte
kevin spacey ist durchgehend house of
cards berühmt geworden und vorher kann
ihm keiner das ist ja völliger
schwachsinn ist alles gar nicht schuld
alles konnte ich habe nein habe ich
meinte nur bevor sie den kommentaren
gleich immer so ich dachte schon
gewaltig drahtlose der serie an bord ist
wie hat wollte der serie noch eine sache
gerade sagen aber das bringt ihr das
wenn wir wenn wir sachen aus dem kopf
fallen gar nicht sagen kann in erstmals
kann die gedärme sind ist okay
jedenfalls wollte ich house of cards
gucken da geht's halt viel um
amerikanische politik und so auch oder
man muss halt ein bisschen
hintergrundwissen haben mut juli
zugesagt um das ganze halt wirklich so
zu verstehen warum der dann die und die
aktion ausführt muss hier bei allen
serie muss hier reinkommen
sonst ist das eine serie die ich auf
jeden fall noch gucken möchte also ich
mag halt wirklich so serien
ich mochte zum beispiel auch den film
transzendenz mit johnny depp da den 9
fand ich richtig richtig geil ich mochte
zum beispiel aber auch den film kennt
den nonstop
ja aber das euro obert das war doch der
ball ging zurück
neeson recht ich fand dass lärm nie so
grauenvoll dokumente mit dran erinnern
also der ganze film war echt super aber
dann am ende dass es wirklich nur so
eine stumpfe entführung war dann hat
mich so ein bisschen enttäuscht muss ich
ehrlich sagen aber ansich falle weil der
film richtig richtig toll fand ich weil
gerade diese angst im flugzeug dass man
wirklich von einer höheren gewalt da
irgendwas hörigen wahl von irgendeiner
person die man nicht kennt im flugzeug
ist man halt wirklich hilft los dass da
fand ich super dass darüber sondern so
ein film gemacht wurde fand ich stark
sonst fand auch ihr einfach mal an was
sind denn die serien die ezb früher
geschaut aber das war auch eine frage
mit ihn behalten
ich hab ich schon mal meinen senf dazu
abgeben dann ist jetzt bergmann dran
ja eigentlich also heutzutage kommt zb
gar keine serien wenn ich hab einfach
weiß ich nicht mehr so viel zeit für
serien ich bin vermutlich man im ablauf
beschäftigt ist die einzige serie die
ich mal so gucke irgendwie ich mag es
auspacken glaube ich gerne ich mochte
früher weichen riesiger twenty four fan
was ich heute eigentlich cookies und nur
seichte sitcom king of queens community
fand ich sehr sehr sehr sehr geil damit
jede einzelne folge von gesehen weil das
ist die community community college und
über so eine soziale lerngruppe die
absolute geheimtipp
leider gottes die wurde jetzt auch
abgesetzt irgendwie finde ich mega
traurig über ein paar studenten die halt
ein bisschen älter sind und heilversuch
unter ihren abschluss nachzuholen und da
spielt diese asiate von hangover mit und
dieses horn arena benannt ist kommt das
kommt daher dass wissen die wenigsten
leider ist das hobby bekannter als die
serie selbst noch sagen wollte
da hattest bergmann dass irgendwas
gesagt so von wegen ja ich kenne ich
alle filme aus wenn ich du hast in einem
twitter profil kannst du das denn da
stehen hat filme league aber naja ich
mich auch immer ich kenne alle filme aus
grundsätzlich geht das nicht zu essen
aber hast du irgendwie eisen oder so für
mich habe ich bin noch gar nicht mein
gegangen ich bin dabei jedoch nicht mehr
zusammen zu werkeln aber das wird jetzt
kommen gleich oder die monster ist aber
ich bin schon ein bisschen vorbereitet
jetzt also ich hab mir jetzt karten
schwert gemacht wow wow wollte mir
eigentlich gar kein schwert machen
jetzt habe ich mir nach rom gemacht
sondern wenn ich den dom kultury
professioneller wieder aber hier das
muss ich natürlich bergmannstag und
sowas habe ich auch noch vergessen es
sind also die serien die schaue ich die
schaue ich aktiv bin wirklich neue
folgen aktiv rauskommen und so aber
ansonsten schaue ich immer so nebenbei
ganz gerne ja wenn ich nachts dann
irgendwie mal doch so dazu kommen die
glotze eine stunde einzuschalten und
south park läuft dann fällt ganz klar
die wahl auf south park außer mitten im
leben läuft dann fällt natürlich ganz
klar
ein weg ja weil ich eine brauche ich
habe keine dreister diebstahl morgen
hier was jedoch nicht wir brauchen gar
kein wasser aber du kannst ja noch was
in flamschen glaube ich habe glaube ich
ja ich hab gar keine sahne da ich hab
schon ein bisschen was gebraten mit der
essen braucht dann kommt auch gerne zu
mir ich versuche ich mit ein paar guten
buletten langsamen mehr für samenraub
täters ist die folge
auch mal wieder vergessen nie was ich
habe echt richtig cool finde gerade ist
dass das ich weiß nicht wer auf die idee
gekommen ist aber dass wir wirklich uns
dieses villiger dorf zu eigen machen und
dass da so richtig was raushauen weil
ich bin dort schon dabei einfach die
wege so ein bisschen zu verschönern
überall fackeln hinzusetzen und ich
denke wenn wir das ganze irgendwann
durch zum beispiel die gremmel wege wenn
wir jemand hocharbeiten und wir machen
da in wie marvel wege hin oder immobilie
überhaupt gibt halt das für die stadt
immer so ein bisschen schöner gestalten
von folge zu folge
finde ich schöner chaos idee das
geschenk als dankeschön bergmann
bergmann ist man wieder hier wirklich
wirklich am start muss ich ja genau die
hälfte hier wieder chaos
ich mache jetzt einfach mal so eine
komische danach noch fackeln deswegen
ich bin doch nicht abgefackelt leute was
ist mit euch los habt ihr euch nicht um
das saucen gekümmert sie sind der fünf
mal gestorben
bgn zeitlich ja ich nur drei mal
loswerden discounter einbauen sollen man
man man ja moment gleich fünf oder so so
kasch vielen muscheln alter dass er
unglaublich
lasst doch mal ne tue hier in ruhe so
mit fackeln hier gibt's mal kurz sieben
stück in die menge geschossen
sie bilden nämlich sieben jahre
behandelt seine mitbewohner freundlich
du ja das ist das ist doch mein priester
der sorgt für mein seelenheil der gehört
wie gesagt das ist das ist eigentlich
nur zierde
wieso kriegt der bergmann 7 und ich noch
hier weil ich jetzt noch drei habt die
sieben war eigentlich für euch beide
aber weil man ja nicht teilen kann und
einfach wieder da es ist schon blöd
berger hält einfach nur so viel wir
erstmal gar nicht mehr rede ich nicht
weil ich wollte gucken ob man nicht auch
schon hier bei 1 6 4 aus holz kohle
machen kann ich probier's einfach mal ja
kann man das kann man seit dem start von
minecraft glaube ich sogar oder nein
nach holzkohle nicht ich glaub ich
glaube das geht schon hier sind keeper
dass sie mal explodieren damit ein
bisschen holz holt
war das mein haus das war glaub ich
nicht dahin sollte nicht ich hoffe es
war nicht da eins zu sagen ist wahlweise
so also du stehst da gerade unheimlich
nahe ist das ist das ist nicht da hinaus
glaube ich glaube ich ich wollte das
auch ab dass da ist dass das dein foto
kraus kam sondern ja genau
ja also wir hier brauche ich das holz
jedoch manchmal vielleicht auch wasser
hast ne die hab ich nicht werden nicht
mehr alle sind bestimmt wir haben gerne
wenn ich noch sagen wollte auch gibt es
glaub ich blumen die leuchten nehme eine
fackel verdammt was ich noch sagen
wollte die serien die ich früher geguckt
habe nur pokemon das ist so kommt ein
pokémon doch yukio pokémon und yu gi oh
das war bei mir wirklich das einzige was
ich regelmäßig geschaut habe wo ich
damit ja auch die handlung verfolgter
wie sie dann von stadt zu stadt gezogen
sind zumindest bei pokemon was so sind
sie dann von stadt zu stadt gezogen und
haben da ihre kämpfe ausgeführt in den
verschiedensten arien und der roxy man
alle mädels an gemacht hat nie eine
abgekriegt und alles und dann immer für
alle gekocht und dann wollte ich auch
immer dass dieser rocco damals für mich
kocht weil das immer so unglaublich
lecker aus und weil sie nicht und ich
kam zur judo und dragonball wirklich
erst dadurch dass ich einmal weil meine
eltern nicht zu hause ich war alleine zu
hause und ich durfte wirklich täglich
eine stunde fernsehen
mittlerweile ist es irgendwie in der
erziehung der in der erziehung von
eltern irgendwie so im kopf verankert ja
wir geben unserem kind alles die dürfen
auch den ganzen tag fernsehen
ich weiß nicht warum ich finds auch doof
ehrlich gesagt zu viel input dadurch zu
bekommen aber ich durfte halt wirklich
damals so eine stunde fernsehen ich
wollte natürlich immer mehr aber
mittlerweile finde ich halt ganz gut
dass ich wirklich nur so wenig bekommen
habe kann ich doch nicht so gut aber nur
dadurch habe ich wirklich rubio und
dragonball entdeckt weil damals was
wirklich auf pokito gab es noch damals
rtl2 pokito lief pokémon um 14 uhr
direkt nach der schule pokémon geschaut
dann kam mal zwei folge meiner eltern
anhalt weg und ich dann so wie bed boy
ist es 15 uhr ich guck mal weiter dann
kann man dieses intro von jogi und ich
dachte das ist meine serie a kam einem
reizvollen duell
und bekam eine besser rein und meinte
dann so du hast du darfst eigentlich gar
nicht so lang gucken und so was alles
wenn ich da nur sehr okay ich mache es
aus ich war echt wirklich total perplex
stand in dem moment dass sie halt
wirklich einfach wieder kamen und hallo
rechtsmeinungen benutzen warte ich ihnen
in unserer serie mit einem ganzen
monolog am bergmann und ich es geschafft
sich nur über minecraft zu verständigen
aber irgendwie war irgendwie ganz putzig
da das war eine meisterleistung wann
waren waren süßer moment ich denke ich
mache nie wieder monologe warb weiter
für schwache da konnte ich bin noch
nicht mal fertig bin noch nicht mal
fertig werden
minecraft tisch ja ich wollte gott sagen
hey hier die ganzen leute häuser zu
zerstören kann austria gar nicht wie das
ablaufen das ganze holz ja das kannst du
musst du dir von den bäumen der umgebung
wohl findet das ist okay so dass martin
schon echt auch immer so ja ich renne
irgendwelchen war neven du einfach was
auf dem kühlschrank willst was zugleich
den kühlschrank von den nachbarn direkt
kaputt oder so und jetzt nicht aber ich
habe ein paar sachen raus ist das bei
euch nicht so dass ein darf und der kuh
mit studium ist es wohl bei uns im dorf
hin kommt aber langsam miranda mir kam
heute auch sein nachbar einfach die
fassade hochgeklettert und wie sieht
jetzt ein bisschen was abgeholt ich
wünschte gerade das wäre irgendwie hero
wohnen jeder ecke wo diamanten auf einer
höhe sind ja aber das ist halt hier hart
hart erarbeitet jetzt werde erst ein
paar schöne buden gebaut ich habe auch
in den kommentaren von niemanden gelesen
weniger reden mehr spielen ist der
falsche ansatz das ist tatsächlich hier
so ein lager projekt nur nebenbei ein
bisschen das mappack gespielt wird und
natürlich wollen wir auch viel format
berg erkunden ich habe auch schon viel
mit dem ocean kreft erklärt aber
konzentriert euch trotzdem auch bitte
auf die wundervollen team wir geben uns
sehr viel mühe mit der auswahl und
werden halt gleichzeitig von skeletten
abgeschossen so läuft das hier in
eigentlich mein thema noch eben zu
beenden und damit werden wir dann
wahrscheinlich auch die folge beendet
dann werdet ihr die nächste folge morgen
beim herr bergmann auf dem kanal
anschauen können bei mir war es dann
halt so dass meine mutter mir dann
gesagt hat okay du darfst weiter gucken
ich gehe jetzt mal hier die ausnahme
dass das weil ich hab kohle gefunden ist
das schön du darfst weiter schauen und
so und ich hab's zu halten sind hat ist
dass kohl oder eisen sogar und ich hab's
halt weiter geschaut und dann wurde ich
halt wirklich muss man sagen süchtig von
dieser serie gehabt ein pokémon bisschen
vernachlässigt und dementsprechen kann
ich jetzt sagen dass sowohl der burg
gebaut ein bisschen von la rioja bezahlt
die versprechen kann ich halt jetzt
sagen das wirklich meine kindheit
komplett durch pokémon und yuko geprägt
wurde und auch meine ersten spiele habe
ich ja in der letzten oder vorletzten
folge schon gesagt mein erstes spiel war
auch pokémon und das ist auf jeden fall
eine wunderschöne geschichte die ich
gerade jetzt hier tonnen quartal eine
lovestory sondergleichen die filmrechte
dafür immer wieder ist es verständlich
darfst du alles vor film ja klasse freue
ich mich drauf mit bestimmten ein
richtiger hit ja genau
genau den autofreunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat und euch das gefällt wenn
wir so ein bisschen über themen reden
oder wenn die allgemeine tipps etwas wie
eventuell besser machen können sollen
dann schreibt uns das einfach in die
kommentare oder zeigt es uns mit allem
mag ich und dann will ich sammle
spitzhacke kaputt und ich gehe wieder
nach oben aber das werdet ihr nicht
sehen sondern das werdet ihr morgen beim
herr bergmann auf dem kanal sehen
deswegen würde ich sagen meine schönen
tag und